Comment here as you go...
Make your observations here
Motivation - is it the medium or the message ?
Motivation - is it what the medium does, or what you can do with it?
How might motivations be reflected in codes of ethics - editorial vs advertising vs journalistic?
How does your picture of Graham at this point, relate to the depictions in the preparatory content?
What are the implications of G's comment on 'addict-consent' for photo stories depicting addiction?
How does Graham's personal conflict here contribute to the issue of 'addict-consent'?
What does Functional Addiction look like?
Where do you see stereotypical depictions of addiction working?